this tastes like the sweet
beginning
of the end of my diet
[Music]
hey guys i'm brenda i'm a tasty producer
and today we will be comparing homemade
versus store-bought twinkies i need to
know if we can duplicate this cake at
home and make it taste even better
let's get cooking
twinkies are known for its fluffiness
which is why we tested a variety of cake
batter recipes that would give us that
airy bouncy texture typical of twinkies
the conclusion lots of egg whites and a
mix of flowers
at spur of the egg whites you want to
whisk this with a hand mixer until you
get soft peaks like this one cute
[Music]
we are including egg yolks because it
really gives the batter an irresistible
flavor and that really pretty golden
color that makes twinkies so appealing
earlier i mentioned the use of various
flowers we are actually adding cake
flour because it is lighter and adds
fluffiness and all-purpose flour just to
add a little density which should give
us a cake that is not too heavy not too
airy it would just be like twinkies
[Music]
because you want to preserve your air
bubble population to keep the fluffiness
factor strong you want to gently fold
the batter to mix it and definitely do
not stir full speed we're adding a
little butter and milk mixture for
flavor and texture you see the butter
adds a little tenderness which is
definitely what we're looking for let's
add a little vanilla because what's a
cake without it
i went crazy and i got me all this
choice to make twinkies but i'm gonna
show you how to turn that batter into
twinkies without needing any of this
if times are rough or you simply like to
save your box get a container like any
one of these two just go and grab that
forget and potato in your kitchen grab
some aluminum foil and then mold it like
a twinkie using the potato or one of the
containers no worries i'm including
detailed instructions in the description
this will take 15 minutes to bake
not a lot the results i mean you get
what you pay for man
if twinkies were born with a fleshy look
and wrinkles that's what you just got
[Music]
first up the twinkie maker yep this
actually exists and if you have about 30
dollars to spend it's yours
perfect if you have no access to an oven
best part you get bouncy cakes in about
seven minutes
the results if a twinkie was a
millennial girl who overuses photo
editing on social media this would be it
if you do have an oven then you can get
baking molds eight to fifteen dollars is
going to give you a variety of options
it takes 13 minutes to bake and you're
done and the result is incredibly
similar to an actual twinkie
i'm moving forward with this normal
looking twinkie but you can go ahead and
pick your favorite
[Music]
you can cheat it like me and grab some
marshmallow fluff add a little bit of
milk to make it more manageable and move
on if a twinkie doesn't have the classic
three holes that thing is not a twinkie
so we gotta get them for a homemade
version be firm and keep a steady flow
you shouldn't have to wonder what the
cream filling is if you did it right
and you're done
and now for the store version obviously
here's the fluffy
classic nostalgic cake
[Music]
these are of course the fluffy treats
with cream filling that you grew up with
[Music]
[Applause]
let's break this down in terms of price
the store-bought version wins
texture-wise guys the store-bought
version is very fluffy very soft but the
homemade version is extra fluffy extra
soft preparation-wise look you can get a
little tiring especially if you have
lizard arms like mine but once you move
on from that stage and you see that
better becoming the very version of such
a classic cake guys
priceless what's life after that i have
to add customization as a category here
because the twinkie does lend itself to
that some people cover in chocolate some
people add extra feelings but the
homemade version look i went a little
crazy as always and made some with
chocolate made colorful ones
flavor i asked six people around the
office and four out of those six said
that they go for the homemade version i
have to agree when you bite into one of
these homemade versions you feel the shy
presence of sugar and eggs because
everything's blend really really well
it's just the
definition of harmony in food
that's what i'm talking about
boom boom
you